there's always a man there's always a
city there's always a leak Bioshock the
collection has been spotted in the wild
once again I'm Lucy and welcome to your
plasmid fuelled gamespot news update
Bioshock the collection has been rated
for Xbox one by a Taiwanese regulation
board although the game has not been
officially announced by publisher 2k
games this is the third indication that
the collection is on the way the rating
was spotted by twitter user life lower
who posted a link to the listing
although a release date is of mentioned
the rating does feature what could be
box art for the game in September 2015
South African retailer raro listed
Bioshock collection for Xbox one and
PlayStation 4 following this the Brazil
advisory rating board published a
listing for Bioshock the collection
further details on the collection have
not been revealed but a likely scenario
would be that it features bioshock
bioshock two and bioshock infinite along
with each games post-release dlc in
february2014 Bioshock series creator
irrational games effectively closed down
development on further Bioshock games
have been taken over by 2k Marin as of
yet no brand new entries in the series
have been announced however 2k games
parent company take 2 has said the
Bioshock franchise has not yet reached
its creative or commercial piece so
would you head back to rapture or do you
want to see a new bioshock game let me
know in the comments below or come find
me on Twitter I met Lucy James games for
the latest on bioshock keep it gamespot